DAVID GLAZER: Welcome,
everyone.
Thanks for coming to
the fireside chat.
Hope you're all having
a good I/O so far.
I know I am.
Google's a big enough company
that we all learn things about
what other parts of Google are
doing at this event and have
some of the same reactions you
all do to the cool stuff
that's happening above
us or on screen.
So by way of introduction, I'm
actually going to have a seed
question for each person
on the panel.
We're going to go through.
I'll do a short intro to who
they are an ask them a
question so you can hear
everyone's voice, know what
they're experts on.
And then we have a mix of
questions that some of you
have submitted online already.
We had that link open for
a couple of days.
And we have questions everywhere
from Cape Cod to
Bangalore to Belgium queued
up from online.
And we'll also do live
questions here.
But let me just go down this
list in order here.
So Joseph, Joseph Smarr.
If you could introduce yourself
and your role.
And then I have a question for
you about the Google History
API that we announced yesterday,
and what is it?
What's going on there?
JOSEPH SMARR: Cool.
Hi, everybody.
I'm Joseph.
I'm an engineer on Google+.
I've been working on Google+
since it began.
I was very involved in the
creation of circles and the
sharing model initially,
hence the t-shirt.
And then a bunch of stuff
across the site.
And recently I've been focused
on this History API that we
just launched yesterday.
And the basic thinking there, if
you haven't seen it, is we
want you to be able to pull in
all the activity you're doing
on and off Google but share
it on your own terms.
Just like with circles, I can
really choose exactly who I
want to share with each time,
you want to be able to do the
same thing with activity while
still taking advantage of the
fact that we are living our
lives increasingly digitally.
So all the things you might want
to talk about in the real
world like where you've been
or what you've seen or what
you've read or what you've
bought or what
you've eaten or whatever.
Now I'm increasingly reading my
books online and watching
my videos online and all
that kind of thing.
So we should be able to help
you share with that.
And so the way it works, it's
kind of like if you've used
instant upload for Google+,
where every time I take a
photo my camera, it's privately
and automatically
uploaded to the cloud.
And then I can go through and
just review the photos and
then share out the
ones that I want.
And so it's giving me that
the efficiency of having
everything queued up
for me, but where
I'm still in control.
And so we've opened up an API
where you guys can now write
anything you want from whatever
app you're doing.
So for example, we already
showed Last.fm did an
integration where every song
I listen to comes into my
personal history, and then I
can choose to share out the
ones that I want.
And that's really useful for
something like music where I
really don't want to spam my
friends with every single song
I'm listening to.
But if I discover a new artist
and it's got the cover art
right there and there's a link
to go check out the band, it's
really nice to be able
to say, oh yeah.
I was listening to that song a
lot, and I should share it.
So that's basically the idea.
And it's just a developer
preview right now.
We still want to get enough
content into the system that
we can do more and more
interesting things with it.
But you go opt in today and
start programming against it.
It's really easy to do.
And you'll see your stuff show
up right in Google+.
DAVID GLAZER: Thanks, Joseph.
And for anyone who wants to know
more about History, you
can ask questions.
But also, there's a History
session immediately after
this, in this same
room at 5:15.
So Chee, down here from Seattle
Kirkland, Chee Chew.
Could you tell us a little
bit about Hangouts?
I know you did a fireside chat
yesterday on Hangouts.
But for people who weren't
there, what's the Reader's
Digest version?
CHEE CHEW: So I'm Chee Chew.
I'm Engineer Director for
real-time communications,
which includes Chat and Hangouts
and Google Voice.
And we had a session
yesterday.
And the message that I have for
folks through this about
the platform, the API aspect
is that we try to make it
really, really simple and very
flexible to enhance your
applications with Hangouts.
You can iframe your app in
really quick, very little
code, and then just add on
additional functionality and
build upon it.
So almost any app that you have
on the web, if it has
collaboration where multiple
people want to use it
together, it's super, super easy
to add Hangouts to it.
And then you can make it richer
and richer from there.
DAVID GLAZER: Thank you, Chee.
Seth, one of the newest
Googlers on the panel.
If you could introduce
yourself.
But also talk a little bit
about, we did a launch the day
before I/O started of
recommendations on the +1 button.
And tell us a little bit about
why a publisher might care.
SETH STERNBERG: Yeah.
So hey, I'm Seth Sternberg.
And I'm a product manager
now focusing
on all things platform.
And I came in through the recent
acquisition of Meebo.
DAVID GLAZER: Set was
one of the founders
and the CEO of Meebo.
He's being modest.
SETH STERNBERG: So I've been
here for all of two weeks.
Now one thing that was really
nice when I got here--
so as Meebo, we were hearing
requests from publishers all
the time via e-commerce sites
or travel sites or folks
putting out content that they
really wanted content
recommendations in their site.
They wanted some way to kind of
say to a user, hey, here's
some other stuff that you may
really want to see on my site
based on who you are and what
your interests are.
And so when I got--
when the collective we got into
Google a couple weeks
ago, we discovered that, in
fact, the Google+ team was
already working on that,
which is awesome.
And the reason why publishers
were asking us for that so
much-- and Google had heard
the exact same thing--
is, as you all know, a lot of
the traffic you get to your
websites today comes from
the side door, right?
It either come from people
doing a Google search.
And they land on a specific page
of yours, a particular
part of your site.
Or they come in from
a social stream.
But they're not going through
your front page.
And so you lose the opportunity
to program to
those users.
So with content recommendations,
you can have
a user land on the hotel's
booking page for the hotel
that they're looking
for in Cabo.
But you then might have the
opportunity to also point them
to some content about Cabo as
well and move them around your
site, rather than having only
a very transactional
relationship with that user.
Hence, content recommendations.
DAVID GLAZER: Great,
thank you.
Ken.
Ken Norton is--
we've seen a lot of talk about
mobile at Google I/O. And for
one of this data points that we
announced is that Google+
is now seeing more users on
mobile than on desktop.
So with that, what's the news?
What have we done to help
mobile developers in
particular?
KEN NORTON: Yeah, that number
is pretty astonishing.
I've been at Google coming
up on six years.
And just watching mobile users
going from being kind of an
interesting side project, to a
slight distraction, to OK,
something you need to start
taking seriously, to wow, oh
my god, to wow, we
should really be
building for mobile first.
So I think it's really amazing
to think that more than half
of Google+ users
are on mobile.
And I know you as developers
have been watching the same
thing happen.
And so what we've announced in
developer preview is a Google+
SDK for iOS, Android, and mobile
web to make it easier
for you to bring Google+
into your app.
And that includes a sign
in with Google+.
It includes +1 buttons.
It includes making it easier
to share to Google+ from
within your app.
And then also the
new History API.
So we're really excited
about it.
It's currently in developer
preview.
iOS is ready now.
Android is coming within
the next few weeks.
It's part of the Google Play
services that will be going to
all phones with Google
Play store, I
think Froyo and above.
So it's a pretty wide base.
We're pretty excited about it.
DAVID GLAZER: Thank you, Ken.
And Bradley.
Bradley Horowitz is
our VP of product
management for all of Google+.
Curious.
You've been walking the halls,
watching the events, involved
in a lot of the material
coming up here.
When you look at what the news
of the week was from the eyes
of a developer, what do you
think developers should pay
the most attention to
over this week.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Well I think
the high-level message is that
we deeply, deeply care and
depend on making you
successful.
And all the investment that we
make at Google I/O is really
in the interest of making
you successful.
We understand that what you want
are distribution channels
and the opportunity to impact
the world and ultimately
change the world.
That's what we are trying
to provide for you.
And I think some of the momentum
story, big shared
numbers around Google+ adoption,
the number of
Google+ upgrades, the engagement
in the stream.
All of this bodes toward
the inevitable success,
we feel on the team.
And we want to sweep you up into
that and invite you to be
a part of it.
And I think another message I
hope is resonating with folks
is that we are pretty good
listeners, and pretty attuned
to the dialogue that's
happening between us.
And so as we invite you onto the
platform, it's intended to
give you a voice and give us the
feedback that will help us
shape the product, shape
the platform.
And we understand how much
you have to offer in that
relationship.
And so these fireside chats
really are one means of
dialoguing with you.
But those that have been working
with Google for a
while know that we have many,
many channels of communication
and depend on them to ensure
that we're building a product
that does indeed work for you
and ensures your success as
well as ours.
DAVID GLAZER: Thanks
you, Bradley.
And I realized I forgot
to introduce myself.
I'm David Glazer.
I run platform engineering
for the Google+ platform.
So all of the different aspects
that hopefully we'll
be talking about.
So if any of you all have
questions, please
come up to the mics.
I'll be trying to mix online
and live questions.
But there's mics in both
aisles, so feel free.
I'm going to start with--
and by the way, if any of you
submitted questions and we
don't get to them.
There were a bunch of really
good questions about the
Google+ product and the end user
experience and features
and roadmap that we're
not covering today.
So they're just out of scope
for this session.
So if you don't hear us get
your question, that's why.
But the top question that
came in from Cape Cod,
Massachusetts was, when will
the full API for Google+ be
available to everyone?
The current API, which only
allows access to public data
and can't be used to post
is pretty much useless.
And that's not filtered.
That could have been a more
harshly worded question.
That was actually a fairly
honestly worded questions.
And I'll take that one myself.
I think that this is something
we thought a lot about in the
early days of the platform,
before Google+
launched over a year ago.
And we deeply wanted, as Bradley
just said, to make
sure we were building a platform
that worked for
developers, and that let you all
build on and enhance and
extend, build something that was
great for our joint users.
And at the same time, we knew
there were a couple of failure
modes around doing that.
The obvious failure mode is
don't give you tools.
Well, that's an easy
one to avoid.
And this question is saying,
I want more tools.
Understood.
But there's some other
failure modes that
we've seen out there.
And one of them is to provide
tools before we know if it's a
good idea, and then to change
our mind, and then to change
our mind again, and then to
change our mind again.
And we've heard from when I went
out and talked to a bunch
of people who have been
building social media
applications on top of the
platforms, what it felt like
to be whipsawed by policies
and changing rules of
engagement on other platforms.
And we wanted to avoid that.
And the other failure mode that
we've seen is that it's
possible with a platform that
has insufficient guidelines or
tone or just doesn't nudge the
experience in the right
direction, to build something
that creates a
tragedy of the commons.
Where the more that people build
on the platform, the
more it hurts the overall
community and takes away from
that momentum Bradley talks
about, which is what we are
all getting the value from,
is making users happy.
So when we put those all
together, our answer was to
take a pretty deliberate
approach to rolling out APIs.
So we have a bunch of APIs that
are out there and are
completely widely available,
including a read-only API to
access public information
from Google+.
Pretty small subset of what you
might want to do, but that
one is 100% available.
We have another large set of
APIs that let you, in a
user-mediated way, help your
users interact with Google+.
And these are both desktop and
mobile and some of the brand
new mobile SDK widgets.
In mediated ways, where you can
say to a user, I want to
let my users share to
the Google+ stream.
Great.
Here's a way to do it.
That involves putting
up pixels that
the user clicks through.
And that means that we know the
users are being thoughtful
about their posting.
We have other APIs that are
available to limited sets of
partners where we're
experimenting with things.
We're saying, we think this
is a good set of APIs,
but we're not sure.
And we want to be able to work
with a small enough set of
partners that we can actually
get feedback from them and
have a relationship with the
people who are using it.
So that if we change our mind,
we're changing our mind in the
context of a relationship.
And once we know what sticks,
we're comfortable opening up
more widely.
And then finally we have, as
Joseph talked about earlier,
we this week added the Google+
API in developer preview.
Which is open to everybody.
And does add, we think, a lot of
the capabilities that we've
been hearing people asked
for from the API.
But adds them in a way that
has a circle-centric,
user-centric twist.
Which is what we like to do is
stay pivoted around the users.
JOSEPH SMARR: Yeah.
I was just going to add a quick
comment about that that
I think ties together the
themes David said.
Which is one of the things we
could really use help from you
guys is figuring out what is
the right surface area, for
example, to take the
example of getting
posts into the stream.
That works well enough for
developers and the use case
that makes sense for them.
But also works well enough
for Google+ and users.
And I think it's complicated.
Because when you go to share in
Google+, it's a rich post.
You might have an attachment.
You might want to choose which
circles you're sharing to.
You might want to choose
or to notify them.
We built a lot of richness
because we think sharing is a
pretty nuanced thing.
And so it's pretty hard to
capture that if you're doing
an automated post, and the
user's not in the loop.
So if you pull up a share box,
well, we control the UI there.
So you can have all that
functionality, and you can
pre-fill the content.
And if you write to the History
API, one of the
reasons it makes sense to do
besides giving the user that
buffer space is that when the
user goes to share it, they
then can go and choose that
sort of stuff when they're
sharing it.
And I think obviously there
are cases where using a
different API and having that
generate a post makes sense.
And so figuring out how much
of that is just a really
complicated API where you can
basically recreate all of the
same UI on your end, versus
setting some policy in advance
like always post
to this Circle.
There's lots of possible
solutions we
could come up with.
And I think we're really
open to talking
through specific examples.
But if it's just, hey, I'm
already cross-posting to these
four other sites.
I want to add Google+.
That's generally not going to
work because we each have a
different surface area.
It's not the same as a tweet or
a different kind of post.
For anyone who wants to really
think through the nitty gritty
about how that would work and
present this use case that
says, here's an app I'm doing
where it really does make
sense for the user to set it
and forget it or use my UI,
but ultimately, having it
take action on Google+.
Come show us because I think the
devil is in the details.
And we could actually use
some more clarity there.
DAVID GLAZER: That, by the way,
is almost exactly the
same answer we give internally
when some internal team says,
how about launching
such and such API.
And we have that same
conversation.
JOSEPH SMARR: Right.
As you guys know, we're trying
to unify Google right now.
There's lots of fairly separate
products that are
trying to get unified.
So we have a mini version of
this platform problem just
getting ourselves unified.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: I want to
add a little bit too.
One of the things we hope you
guys have noticed is that we
have a very high
velocity team.
Things are changing.
Authors who wrote the Getting
Started with Google+ guide, by
the time the effort was done,
Google+ had changed entirely.
And they sort of had
to start over.
This is not what you want
when you're a developer.
You don't want to be chasing
after moving target.
So I think part of what Dave's
talking about in terms of the
maturity of the platform and
ensuring that we're not
whipsawing the developers around
is getting to a point
of stability where we're
confident that your efforts to
build against that platform
are going to
be time well spent.
And that we're not moving so
fast that in an effort, you're
sort of chasing after us.
So that's an important aspect
of that as well.
DAVID GLAZER: I agree.
Thank you.
Question from the floor.
AUDIENCE: OK, I'm going
to have to call
bullshit on you guys.
You answered the wrong
W question.
DAVID GLAZER: The wrong W.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
You answered the, why don't we
have it instead of when.
When is a time frame.
There was no time frame
specified in
any one of your answers.
When can also be specified
conditionally too.
Like, when we figure out X,
we're going to do this.
But there's no there's no way
to hold you guys accountable
to when is it going
to be offered.
Now to the general question
of a use case.
I think it's important that we
separate two different users
and consumers of
your products.
Because there's no reason why
you have to solve everything
for both sets of users.
So specifically, there's a set
of users that are consumers
that may install apps and
not have a contractual
relationship, necessarily,
with their apps.
But then there's business
owners.
Who, we have the product APIs
and such like that.
But there's no write APIs to
use pages, to update pages,
which are primarily focused
on businesses.
And for my case, my business
benefits--
basically we act as a user's
agent to manage
their social web.
And so we are heavy contractual
relationship
involving exchange of money and
everything else like that.
Which is a whole lot different
than, did my wife install some
app that's messing up
her Google profile.
And I think you don't have to
solve the consumer problem in
its entirety to recognize that
if you have this thing where
you say, are you charging
money for the
person to use your app?
Means that we're held legally
liable at a much higher level
with our customers than
necessarily a consumer app
where they've free
installed it.
So back to the thing
is like when?
And can we break it up
into consumer stuff
versus business stuff?
And let the business stuff get
ahead of the consumer stuff
because of the contractual
relationships.
DAVID GLAZER: Yeah.
Probably several of us have
something to say about that.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: I'm sure a lot
of have something to say.
So thank you for calling
us out on that.
I think implicit in our and
answer were a bunch of those
preconditions.
We will do this when we are
certain that it will not
destroy the user experience.
When the velocity of our team
has stabilized to a point
where we're not whipsawing the
developers around chasing a
moving target, et cetera.
I'm certain that no one on
this panel has a specific
date, if that's what
you're looking for.
I think what you're seeing us
do is, gradually, with the
launch of History, with the
momentum you're seeing, you're
seeing the experiments that we
are running in market right
now play out.
And those learnings accrue
to getting us
closer to this date.
In terms of the use case you
provided, we are working with
a handful--
literally five I think is the
current number-- of partners
that are in a business
similar to yours.
Where they help entities,
business entities generally,
but also sometimes celebrities,
have a presence
on social media sites.
And what we wanted to do was
really understand what is the
effect of having those
relationships mediated.
In a worst case scenario--
and I'm not saying you or others
intentionally do this--
but what happens is
you get brochure.
Where you get sort of least
common denominator things
where a handle is pulled and out
sprays a tweet over here
and a post over here and
a post over there.
And there's absolutely
no engagement.
It's a really inauthentic means
of an entity engaging
with an audience.
And we want to create something
that actually
elevates the conversation.
Where entities participate as
principles in our system and
actually respond to comments.
And don't just refer
to themselves
in the third person.
Where so and so will
be appearing here.
But they actually say, I am.
And they actually refer to
themselves as a person would.
Or we, in the sense
of a business.
And so that is our hope.
And part of what these
experiments are-- and I don't
know that we've ever talked
about this publicly.
But for those experiments we're
running right now, we're
actually looking at, how is the
engagement of posts that
are made through this mediated
system faring relative to
posts where we know that the
author is actually clicking on
a button and watching
and observing.
Is the thesis that these are
lower quality conversations
something that we can measure?
Are there ways that we
can help them help
themselves and improve?
So these are the kinds of
experiments we're running.
But it's all in service of
ensuring that what is special
about what we're building is not
compromised inadvertently.
And I think we all feel like
we're sort of walking down the
aisle with this golden egg.
And we're trembling, and we
don't want to screw it up.
Because we feel the magic
in our system.
Any of you who are deeply
engaged on Google+ and have
been part of this community
understand that there's
something special
going on there.
And we think it's worth
treating right.
And part of our tentative nature
around this is ensuring
that we get it right.
And making sure this experience
isn't compromised.
Not that anyone has a malicious
agenda, but just
unintentional consequences that
could corrupt what is
very special.
JOSEPH SMARR: And so again,
the takeaway is we're not
saying we don't want to do it.
We're saying we want to figure
out how to do it right.
So help us figure out
how to do it right.
And that's going to that next
level of detail on what
integration would look like or
the scenarios that it enables.
DAVID GLAZER: And one thing
to add in particular.
Because I actually expected
this question.
I didn't talk to you, but I've
talked to other people in the
halls who had very similar,
well-grounded, hey, I know how
to do something good for my
customers, how come you won't
let me, basis.
So the update I got this morning
from the team working
in that particular area is
that they are comfortable
saying, we've looked
at that experiment.
We like the results of
that experiment.
Exactly what Bradley said.
We have decided to open that up
more widely for what sounds
like exactly your use case.
I'm still not going to
your W question.
But we've said, yeah we're
going to do it.
And now we're working on the
details of the tactics of
doing it as opposed to the
strategic question we started
with of, is it a good idea.
And the last point I want to
make is I think you're spot
on, on the line you're drawing
between different categories
and the idea of segmenting.
I'm not sure it's a difference
that matters.
But I draw I think the
same line you drew
for different reasons.
It's not between paying
customers and casual users.
It's between supporting the
presence of brands and
entities on Google+ versus
supporting the presence of
people on Google+.
And there's a lot that
could happen.
If I get a personal thank you
note from somebody that I sent
a gift to, there's a lot
of humanity in that.
And therefore, there's a lot
of ways that it could get
messed up if it got run through
a fax machine and an
OCR and whatever.
But when I get communication in
the exact same mailbox from
a hotel, it's not all that
personal to start with.
And I'm not as worried about
breaking the human touch.
So there's a lot more value that
can be added by software
like yours with a lot less
risk to the tone of the
conversation.
JOSEPH SMARR: That said, I hope
one of the things that
Google+ lets us do is blur
that line increasingly.
Because when you see celebrities
or people
representing brands acting
authentically online, it's a
wonderful thing.
I think a lot of Google+
engineers and other folks on
the team are personally--
like Ken posted the post about
Google+ history and then is
responding to feedback directly
and all that.
And so we designed the Circles
model so that there's no hard
line between public
and private or
business and personal.
We tried to make the Plus page
profiles look like personal
page profiles.
So you don't really have to
think about, is this Lady Gaga
the person or Lady
Gaga the company.
And obviously for people who
are less famous, it's even
more of a blur.
Like Bradley, for example.
I don't want him to have to
decide, do I need Bradley
Horowitz TM, the business,
or Bradley the person.
Because I'm going to have this
radically different experience
with my consumers.
Because we're just
in the middle.
And I'm glad we don't
have that.
But then that complicates the
line you're talking about.
DAVID GLAZER: Another question
And then I'm going to do an
online one.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
So I'm just wondering how does
the team really keep its--
what is the mission statement
for Google+?
In a lot of ways you think of
like, when I think of Facebook
or Google+ and like,
what is it for.
And who's using it.
And there's so many possible
scenarios.
And we're just talking a lot
about a lot of them here.
How do you, as a team, think
about how you're going to
focus in on what your
mission is.
And then how do you communicate
that to us as well.
About what is the mission for
Google+ and what is it
actually solving?
Because it's not as laser
focused as some other products
that are much more
clearly defined.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: I'm hogging
the panel here.
And I will surrender
the mic soon.
But that one is just too juicy
for me to pass up.
I love that question.
Vic alluded to this in
the stats he gave.
There are really, I see
it, two missions.
Google is an incredible set
of services that have been
developed over a decade.
Sergey's stunt, if it shows
nothing, is that we have a
healthy disregard for
the impossible.
And we take on these ambitious
crazy tasks.
I remember one of my very first
meetings, where I was
lurking in a meeting
with Larry.
And somebody was explained to
him very thoughtfully why what
he was asking for was impossible
and couldn't be
done in a browser.
And he sort of leaned back and
said, maybe we should build a
browser where this
is possible.
And we did.
He can do that.
We can do that.
We actually have tremendous
resource.
And it's amazing the company
that Google is, and the value
that it provides in users
lives around the world.
It's not perfect.
And if I look at the growth of
the company over the last 10
years, one of the things that
I think we could have done
better at, was thinking
more holistically
about an end game.
What a user's experience would
be like when maps and finance
and self expression and
communication were not siloed
events in a user's life, but
a more holistic approach.
And I think even down to our
management structure, it
didn't really support any
initiatives that tried to knit
together these products so that
they were more than the
sum of the parts.
And to our credit, I think we
have fantastic services that
have changed the world.
But there's still
work to be done.
And I think Google+ plays a big
role in providing that.
And some of this stuff is just
so blatantly obvious.
Like I meet someone at a party,
and I want to connect
to that person.
I have to go figure out, what
is your YouTube handle?
sushiguy21 at YouTube.
What is your Blogger?
Or does he have a blog?
Does she have a blog?
How do I find that blog to
connect to the content that
they're producing?
What is their email address?
I want to get in touch
with the person.
What is their phone number?
There's so many different
touch points to
connect to a person.
There's no good way to
do that at Google.
You have to do a tremendous
amount of effort across all of
our products.
Or in this culture, a
woman gets married,
changes her last name.
Right now there's umpteen places
where you would have to
go on Google and change
your profile to
reflect that change.
This is not a feature.
This is a tragic bug.
And one of the things that
Google+ can do is provide that
social spine that
Vic referred to.
That gives you a simple,
coherent place to express who
you are, who you know, and what
you care about across all
of Google, and ultimately across
the internet if that's
what you wish.
And in doing so, we think we can
provide a better quality
of service for everything
we do.
We can build a better phone, a
better browser, better search,
better ads.
Everything gets elevated when
Google knows a little bit more
about you than just your IP
address and some cookies we've
put on your browser.
And that is very much one of the
missions of Google+ is to
turbo charge the next
decade of our
relationship with our users.
And it's a noble mission.
And we're doing it.
You look at what we did
in Local a month ago.
Where we took Local, which was
this disconnected product, and
brought it into the Google+
fold so that now I can see
restaurant reviews from people
I know and trust.
That's a no-brainer.
And I'm delighted that we've
actually taken that step.
And it's one of many, many more
that we will take over
the coming quarters.
That's a big part
of our mission.
And I think of that in some
ways as remedial.
We're sort of fixing what's
broken about Google and
providing something really
special as a result.
The other part that Vick
mentioned is Google+--
AUDIENCE: Before you go on,
isn't my identity on Google+
just like a long number?
Is there a way to have
a short, like a
Twitter name on Google+?
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Noted.
AUDIENCE: I mean, you talk about
a scenario that makes it
difficult for users.
The ability for me to create
a short tag name from my
identity is totally
missing now.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: I think we
agree with you that that would
be incredibly useful.
So that when you do meet
somebody at a party, you're
not giving them a 16 digit
hexadecimal number.
Yeah, that would be good.
But also, search should
work so well that if
your name is Joe Smith.
We ought to be able to get
that person to you just
knowing Joe Smith and the
guy I met at the party.
And perhaps through social graph
or other means be able
to locate you.
I don't want to diverge
on that.
I want to talk a little bit more
about what I see as the
next part of that mission,
which is I think equally
exciting and important.
It's not fun being late to
market, but it does afford you
certain advantages.
And we had the advantage of
actually talking to people and
asking them what did they like
about existing social networks
and where could they
be improved.
And what we heard resoundingly
was that privacy matters.
And one of the things--
Joseph was instrumental in
coming up with the model that
we call Circles--
context matters.
When you have 2000 friends who
are your kindergarten teacher,
and your co-workers, and your
friends from your church or
synagogue or whatever, there's
almost nothing you can say to
an audience that diffuse
which is meaningful.
It's, checked into the
Olive Garden, traffic
on 101, I hate Mondays.
The quality of conversation is
least common denominator to
appeal to a diffuse audience
when you don't know who you're
talking to.
In the real world, there are
these things called walls.
And there's the laws of physics
that determine how
sound travels through them.
We wanted to introduce
that context.
So that when we're up here on
stage, we have one posture, we
have one tone, we have
one vocabulary.
When we're at home on the
couch with our families
tonight, it's very different.
And that's not a
character flaw.
That's the way human
beings are built.
And we believe Google+ has an
opportunity to reintroduce
authenticity and context
into social networking.
And we see that the level and
quality of discourse, the
dialogue that's happening
in our product.
People are talking about
meaningful things.
We get countless stories about
how Google+ has changed
people's lives.
Has introduced them to people
that they wouldn't otherwise
be connected to or know
in the real world.
There's just a huge opportunity
to make social
networking something more
than ego casting.
Something more than watering
people's farms.
Not that there's anything wrong
with that, either one.
Those are fine too.
But we aspire to
something more.
And we think we have
the framework--
that's the special thing we're
carrying down the aisle-- that
can afford that.
I think Hangouts speaks
to that too.
Going beyond 140 characters
is great.
But what about having the
authenticity, the ability to
look someone in the eye, to
read their body language,
their inflections.
These are really meaningful
cues in human
discourse and dialogue.
And we think we have an
opportunity to introduce them
into our product.
So we think our mission
is noble.
It's not just about the
thrilling prospect of unifying
Google's products.
But creating something which
is markedly different than
anything else in market that
can change the world.
How people communicate, how they
connect, and the quality
of communication that
they're having.
AUDIENCE: So does
your team focus
around a single sentence?
Can you boil all of that last
five minutes into like one
since for--
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
Vic can do that.
JOSEPH SMARR: It's like, making
social work and making
Google work.
And bringing your social
world to Google.
AUDIENCE: I mean, I like the
concept of contextualizing our
communications much better.
Because that's been the big
problem with emails and all
the other things that we have.
And I think it'd be great if
Google could do more to help
make it easier to do temporal
and physical location-based
contextualization.
Like, it's kind of difficult for
me to set up a Circle with
the 12 friends I have who are
here at the I/O. And I'd love
to see where are they all right
now, and do more of that
automatically.
Because you guys know that.
You know where they are.
You could pull those together
for me and give me a much
better view than what I'm seeing
right now in Google+.
JOSEPH SMARR: And that dovetails
with a quick
observation I would make in
support of what Bradley was
saying too.
Which is that one of the things
I think inspires us on
the team is this idea
that while it
seems like, oh my God.
There's social information
overload.
Everybody's tweeting everything
and whatever.
Actually, I think so much of
what matters in our lives is
just not getting captured
at all.
Of all the sessions you've been
to, which ones really
blew your mind.
And is that going to help
somebody else who's deciding
which videos to watch later.
It probably didn't get
captured at all.
And so the more technology can
help you seamlessly capture
and share at the right volume
with the right people in the
right context.
There's just so much more to go
after that we're definitely
not at the stage where we feel
like we're fighting over a
fixed slice of pie.
DAVID GLAZER: All right.
Let me get through a couple
maybe quick ones from online.
Here's one from South
Lake, Texas.
We half covered this already.
Are there plans to add Share,
+1, and comment
features to the API?
Ken, you want to talk about what
we aren't doing there?
KEN NORTON: So I think the first
comment I would make is
back to the mobile SDK.
Which is now much, much more
accessible for mobile
developers to integrate
+1, to integrate
Share with their app.
I think, to go back and touch
on something David said
earlier, around giving
affordances that help make
sure that the user is taking
a thoughtful action.
So widgets and buttons
are part of this.
And being able to do Share box
integration on your site or on
your mobile app.
So I think what you'll see us do
is more in line with that.
Around giving you the capability
to offer to your
user the ability to do
lightweight actions like +1s
or to Share, versus kind of
automated APIs is to do it on
behalf of the user.
DAVID GLAZER: And another
question from Barcelona.
Now that we've launched Google+
Events, will we have
an Events API to add information
on live events?
The easy, standard answer there
is, that's a great idea,
and we have nothing
to announce.
KEN NORTON: Request noted.
DAVID GLAZER: Ken, I'm going to
give you this next one also
because you wear a couple of
hats that put you in the right
place to answer this.
Will Google+ History tie into
Maps, Check Ins, and Events?
KEN NORTON: Great question.
So I think as we think about
History as we've
been building it out.
We start to realize there are
different types of what we
call moments that
are relevant.
So some of them could just be
things like a song you listen
to or an article you read.
But we realize that there's
other types of moments that
are less living by themselves
and more annotating the other
moments in your life.
So where you were when you
checked into a restaurant.
Or where you were when you
were with someone else.
We start to realize that these
are kind of interesting
dimensions that help make
your history come alive.
And it's more vibrant.
So we're definitely thinking
very, very much about that.
We did announce that
Latitude is coming
to the Google+ History.
It's going to be one
of the Google
sources that's connected.
It's very close.
It will be coming in
the next few weeks.
So you'll start to see, if you
visited a city, that showing
up in your Google+ history
as a moment.
And it's caused us to think
about what is the right level
of granularity for these things
to show up in your
Google+ History.
I don't think I want a moment
written every single minute
when Latitude writes
my lat-long.
I want some more meaning
on top of that.
So that's one of the first
sources we have going.
So absolutely location's
critically important.
It came up just a minute ago.
And we think it's a very
important part of the spine
for Google+ History.
AUDIENCE: So I have
two questions.
One is, although I do a lot of
my discussions in Google+, I
lose a lot of my conversations
because they
flow by in the stream.
So there are a few hacks to hold
on to that information,
but none of them are
particularly bookmark-ish.
One that I had offered to me was
to reshare it to myself to
a Circle that had no people
in it, that only I
would be able to see.
But then of course the person
who shared that on a limited
basis sees that I'm resharing
it and goes, hey.
What are you doing resharing?
And then I've got to explain
to them that it's my way of
bookmarking things.
Is there going to be any way
of bookmarking or storing
posts or threads so that you can
go back and look through
them a week later,
two weeks later?
DAVID GLAZER: If anyone
else wants to take it.
I'll say that that's a need
that I've felt personally.
That I have conversations
like that.
And I use exactly the same kinds
of work arounds you're
talking about.
So that's a pain point
that several of us on
the team have felt.
And we don't have an
answer to announce.
But i we agree with the need.
CHEE CHEW: I also
have a point.
The way that we think about
this for conversations and
real-time communications.
I think there I would have two
categories of those to happen.
One are like broad post
announcements, and then the
thread that goes
back and forth.
And that's really interesting.
And also recognize that a lot of
people use the stream as a
quick way of sending an
individual or a couple of
people a message.
So in becomes a small,
private conversation.
And those you want to have
an easy way of finding.
Sometimes the only way finding
that is go to the profile of
the person who sent it.
And you have to remember
who sent that.
That problem is also something
that we're definitely thinking
about in our overall work on
improving real-time chats.
So I guess the message for you
is, this is something we
acutely are aware of.
And we hit that every
day ourselves.
And we're working on figuring
out a better solution.
JOSEPH SMARR: I would say, it's
also just something that
the web needs in general.
I use Instapaper.
I try to bookmark stuff.
I try to leave tabs open
and then use Chrome
to pull stuff across.
None of it really
works very well.
I have labels in Gmail
for [INAUDIBLE],
all sorts of stuff.
And it seems to me like the
two things that go wrong.
One is, that supposedly idle
time when I'm going to want to
bring the queue down doesn't
seem to happen as much as I
would think.
So things just get queued up
and queued up an queued up.
And after a while I'm like, OK,
well jeez, I haven't read
this article for a year.
I'm probably not going to read
it and I just have to DQ it.
And the other thing is that
that consumption pattern
doesn't necessarily fit.
It doesn't remind you,
oh, here's a
little bit of idle time.
Here's the stuff you
could be reading.
And so I think most of those
problems aren't even really
Google+ specific.
Like we often talked about, oh
should we be able to star a
post and go back and see a
stream of starred posts or
something like that.
And you could do that.
Modulate the complexity
and is that
really the right solution.
But it actually isn't really,
I think, Google+ specific so
much as just there's way too
much stuff for me to always
respond everything.
And there's no kind of good
GTD solution for the web.
Of queue it up in the tasks and
someday maybe get through
and pull it down.
And so I hope people can
help build that.
And if you've got a good
solution for that and are just
waiting on some integration with
Google+ to make it really
work well for that, we'll
be very motivated.
Because we all have this
pain point to try to
help you make it work.
AUDIENCE: I guess my reason
for asking the question is
because I'm part of a team
developing an app in Hangout,
called Tabletop Forge, which
lets people play games--
Dungeons and Dragons kind
of games in Hangouts.
And so a lot of prep and talking
goes on before the
game started up that you want
to then reference later on.
The guy says, well, you can make
this kind of a character,
and you make that kind
of a character.
And by the time you actually
get around to doing it two
weeks later, the night before
the game, you can't find the
instructions that
he's given you.
So we'd like to be able to not
only the star those, but even
potentially tag them and connect
them to an event or a
Hangout, or a Hangout
in an event.
Something like that.
CHEE CHEW: I agree.
Actually we do that in
our team as well.
A couple of things that I would
suggest is using hashtags.
So we use a series of hashtags
to help find those and
filter those out.
And then with the addition of
Events where you can have a
Hangout scheduled event.
You can bind and
put information
related to that as well.
AUDIENCE: So my second question,
not to monopolize
the microphone, is that in the
Hangout itself, we'd like to
be able to do a screen capture
of the Hangout.
And using the History API like
you would do in the party the
other night with people going
around taking pictures.
And those pictures immediately
can be put up and shared as
part of the event.
We'd like to be able to capture
the entire screen and
do the same thing.
So right now, we could build
an extension that we would
have to load at the same time
we load the app and
render it in HTML5.
But we still can't get
the film strip.
It would be ideal if the app
could just have a way of
grabbing the screen at
a particular time.
So in our game for example
you roll the dice.
If you roll really poorly,
everybody freaks out and you
can see them.
And it's quite funny usually.
And if you roll really well,
everybody goes, yeah!
So it would really nice to be
able to capture those moments.
Because those are the moments
that define the experience.
Just be able to capture
those automatically.
CHEE CHEW: Right.
That's a great suggestion.
And I agree with you.
It's something that we started
to investigate.
There are some privacy
concerns about that.
So the technology
is one thing.
And then there's the policy,
privacy sort of thing that's
probably will take longer
to resolve.
But yeah, I agree with you.
That's a good use case.
JOSEPH SMARR: I will say that
if you looked at the private
Google+ streams of a lot of
people on the team, you would
see many a screen shot of
Hangouts that includes
something funny happening or
people doing something weird.
Especially because a lot of them
take place later in the
evening, and then everybody's
a little bit laid back.
And so there's a lot
of fun stuff.
So once again, yes we absolutely
feel that plan.
DAVID GLAZER: You wouldn't
happen to be Ed in
Cincinnati, would you?
Because the next question on my
list from Ed in Cincinnati
is, how about write
APIs for pages?
Unlike users, queueing up and
automating posts would rock.
AUDIENCE: No, I'm not Ed.
DAVID GLAZER: But I think
we mostly answered that
previously.
AUDIENCE: But as someone who
was born and raised in
Michigan, I resent being
considered from Ohio.
AUDIENCE: Hey, I'm from Ohio.
AUDIENCE: Oh how I
hate Ohio State.
So it's a little bit of a
follow on to my needs as
someone who is a business
for business.
Is that one of the concerns.
I kind of debated even asking
the question because it's kind
of on of our selling points.
Is that Google, as with many
other large social networking
sites, has this propensity to
take down first and ask
questions later.
And when you're a person, and
it's one thing that hey, my
post about what I did
this evening get
taken down, it's annoying.
When it's marketing
collateral, it's beyond annoying.
And this extends to things
like YouTube videos where
there's various automated DMCA
takedown notices to just
random mother things.
Malicious DMCA filings
and such like that.
First of all, there's no real
API mechanism, unless someone
corrects me.
There's no API mechanism where
a program could monitor for
such a request being filed.
And it doesn't really seem
like there's any sort of
coherent process where it's like
a certain number of days
that you can hire lawyers
and stuff like that.
This is stuff that's really
important for businesses, less
so for people.
And people get irritated
by it, but
businesses get ballistic.
And since we're trying to do
this, we're building this tool
to help businesses manage their
social web presence.
Being able to have a
notification mechanism that
there is some sort of DMCA
filing against our customer's
video is something that
is useful to us.
KEN NORTON: That's a really
great request, thanks.
You've seen, I think, Google
generally becoming more and
more transparent, as transparent
as we can be about
these types of government
requests.
And obviously there's regulatory
issues that we
comply with.
But we're trying to be as
transparent as possible.
And that's a really great
suggestion which is direct
notification.
Which is something
we'll take back.
CHEE CHEW: For something like
Hangouts and real-time events,
it is important for us to take
action pretty much real time.
If you think about like very
popular live sports events.
If we allow them to go and take
them down a couple of
days later, that's
a big problem.
We can't do that.
So for real-time, live,
streaming events, we need to
take pretty quick action when
we have confirmation that
there's a violation.
If you have ideas specific to
your use case where we can
satisfy the requirements that
we have, but also help you,
we're extremely open to
brainstorming and talking
through ideas.
We would love to engage with you
to figure out how we can
satisfy what you're
trying to do.
SETH STERNBERG: One thing I'll
just say, having just joined
the team really recently.
So none of these guys are
probably going to say it.
But I'll just say it
as an observation.
Is you've never seen a group
of people that are more
focused on just, what is the
right answer for the user.
So I remember very well being
on the outside of this team,
wondering why do they make
decisions that they make.
And why is there no API yet.
Like Meebo would have
loved an API.
And then coming onto the inside,
it's very much what is
the right decision
for the user.
And how can we really protect
the user and give the user the
best experience possible.
And sometimes that ends up
meaning that it takes a little
bit longer to get that right
capability in the hands of
developers.
But ultimately, hopefully,
that's better for developers
and the ecosystem
and the users.
DAVID GLAZER: Yeah.
Let's take one from this
side of the room.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I don't want to harp on the
subject, but to ask again
specifically about commenting.
Especially for tools like
ours that ingest data.
Users might not be using the
Google+ API or the Google+ app
or the website.
They might be using some other
reader tool to read data.
But they still want to do
something with it like +1.
You can +1 now, but what
about commenting?
It seems like something that
while you're figuring out how
to let people share stuff within
Circles and control
that aspect of it, they
could still be able
to just add a comment.
A good example is the Instagram
API where you can't
post photos because they want
to control that experience.
But you can favorite them and
you can comment on them.
And that still gives tools that
ingest data a good way to
let you users [INAUDIBLE]
it without taking over
how you post things.
DAVID GLAZER: What company
are you with?
AUDIENCE: I'm with Scope.
It's a social media
aggregation tool.
JOSEPH SMARR: There's
good sense there.
Although I'll point out that
even our commenting surface is
more complicated than
you might think.
Because I can plus mention
people and it auto completes.
And then it expands the access
control of the entire post to
include those people.
And so you could have a
stripped down comments
experience without some
of the complexity.
But everything we touch like
there's actually enough
complexity there that it's
not a no brainer.
That said, I think we're very
eager to do anything that
improves engagement on posts.
Like you said, recently we did
this thing where in Gmail, you
can just comment directly from
the message you get notifying
you about a post.
You don't have to go back over
to the app to do that.
And as you might expect, when
you cut that kind of friction
out, you see a corresponding
increase in engagement.
So I think we're certainly--
that's an area where I think
everyone is pretty well aligned
around making it as
easy as possible to comment as
soon as you see something and
have that urge.
DAVID GLAZER: And let me
ask a specific question
about your use case.
Both about your use case, but
also as a sort of the thought
process we go through in
these kinds of things.
If we gave you a widget
of some sort
that you could invoke.
So you display a post in
your tool, your UI.
You have a comment button.
When someone clicks it, you
invoke our box that pops up,
which lets them type in
a comment on the post.
Would that fully, partially, or
not at all meet your needs.
AUDIENCE: For commenting, and
if we were able to theme it
somehow, then yeah.
That would be OK.
For posting, like using the
services SDK, I went to that
talk today.
That wouldn't really be ideal.
You kind of take people out of
the experience of your app.
But if it's just commenting on
something and you can make it
look something like your
app, that's fine.
Yeah.
But just because half
of our feature
requests are at Google+.
And to allow us to tell the
user, oh, well Google+ is
working on how to do that.
And they're like, well,
why don't you do that?
They just think it's
our problem.
DAVID GLAZER: That
makes sense.
So thank you.
Because that is the path we go
down to try to find that
balance that's good for
the user, good for
the community, and--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, if there was
a way to comment, we would
integrate it now.
JOSEPH SMARR: Perhaps not
surprisingly, we face this
exact challenge even
internally.
So when we've done our
integrations in Gmail and
Search and everywhere else.
We always have this like, hey
could we give you a little
iframeable widget where
we still do all
the rendering ourselves.
Or are there performance UI
reasons why that's not good?
And we've had to kind of do a
mix of solutions depending on
the situation.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thank you.
I've always been a big fan of
Kevin Rose's app, Oink.
And when he moved over to
Google, it was understood that
he was working on Google+.
And then I know he recently
went to Google Ventures.
So I was just wondering what
his influence or his team's
influence has been on Google+
and if they're
still working on it.
And get you to shed some light
on that situation.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
I can take that.
So in general, when we acquire
or hire people, this is sort
of an unusual quirk of Google,
we rarely know what they'll be
working on and neither
do they.
We hire the world's
best people.
They're generalists
most often.
And we give them kid in a candy
store access to what
we're doing.
And they look around and
figure out where
the best fit is.
DAVID GLAZER: Seth did social
media for publishers, so we're
having him redo our
data centers.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Kevin is one
of these amazing entrepreneurs
who has passions around
investing.
He's a prolific Angel
Investor.
He's also a great product
visionary and product mind.
He has passions in
both directions.
We didn't know for sure
where he would land.
We invited him to contribute,
and he continues to
contribute.
He's an avid fan and
user of Google+.
His primary passions lean toward
what he's doing helping
build start ups and companies.
And we have a unique opportunity
for him with
Google Ventures.
Many other team members--
it's a small team.
It's not too many.
But folks like Daniel Burka
continue to contribute on
Google+ and particularly around
the mobile redesigns
that you've seen.
They were contributors there.
Although there was
a ton of momentum
that they walked into.
If you've been watching our
trajectory, you'll have seen
that our sincere redesigns of
mobile pre-date Kevin and his
team joining us.
But they're an incredibly
talented team.
And we always try to optimize.
And the optimization function
includes both where are their
skills, but also where
are their interests.
And where are they going
to get most passionate.
And so we're delighted that
Kevin's at Google, and we
think he's going to do
a ton of good for us
doing what he's doing.
JOSEPH SMARR: And then Milk
guys are definitely making
Google+ better.
And I'd say we've had a bunch
of relatively small
acquisitions of really talented
people that had a
huge impact inside Google+.
I can think of the
[? Say Now ?]
guys or the Planner guys,
and the list goes on.
So Milk's definitely
in that list too.
It's going to be cool.
And it's partly I think why
Google has a pretty start-uppy
feel inside the company.
It's not just that we kind of
built something from nothing
in the last year and
getting it out.
But also that we've got a lot of
that entrepreneurial spirit
in the people on the team.
SETH STERNBERG: Which is
therefore very intimidating
for me and the rest
of the Meebo team.
We've got to do a
good job here.
JOSEPH SMARR: But hopefully it
means that it's your people.
[INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name's JP.
By the way, Hangouts--
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Do you
love pear shooter?
AUDIENCE: No, definitely not.
I love adrenaline though,
but not that much.
Love Hangouts, by the way.
We use it internally
in our company.
We have a small business
to business app.
I think one of the things I hear
from the business guys--
and I think more B2B not B2C.
And I see a lot of potential for
Google+ the platform and
rolling it out for businesses
in our context.
And I think a theme I keep
hearing is just allowing us
the ability to plan our
dev around your dev.
You lead the way.
And if you do want us to
integrate with your APIs then
we're all in.
We're in the Apps Marketplace.
We have a gadget and all
that good stuff.
But as you guys think beyond
features, features, features
and functionality, I'd just like
to open the conversation.
Have you guys be a little
bit more committal.
That's just a theme I keep
hearing is share back.
Because not committing to
a date or committing to
shipping, I get it.
I'm on the other side of the
fence more often than not.
But to enter the dance with you
and go all in on Google
and really build our app around
you guys or with you
guys, that reciprocity would
be really, really helpful.
DAVID GLAZER: Understood
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Hi.
I have two quick questions,
I hope.
One is, you mentioned that it's
important to keep one
identify of the user.
And just as a comment, I
have a Google+ account.
I have a Google App domain,
so I have a
Google+ account there.
I have another domain, so I have
a Google+ account there.
So I have three Google+
accounts.
People add me, they bring my
accounts into their Circles.
It's quite a bit of a mess.
So am I the only one?
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: No.
All of us are in
that situation.
JOSEPH SMARR: Yeah.
We all have our Google accounts
and many of us have
entity domains and
yeah, it's lame.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
Yeah, it hurts.
We're aware of this.
It turns out to be a more
nuanced and complicated
problem than you would imagine
at first glance.
We have felt that way as we have
struggled to provide the
right tools and remedies
to this situation.
But it's not you, it's us.
We're working on it.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And the second question is about
creating more social
engagement or communications,
is there a guide to share or
to do the post?
But really like what about
listening or to actually keep
the conversation alive?
So let's say we generate the
post shared to the circle and
it starts generating
some activity.
A week later, there's really not
much way to actually get
back to that or keep track of
if there's some activity on
the two-week-old post.
JOSEPH SMARR: You're talking
about at the product level?
SETH STERNBERG: That's
actually a really
good feature request.
So you want you want an API that
would send you a signal
that says, hey, this post has
a lot of activity, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Like someone--
that was a wonderful example
about the hike.
I'm planning to hike, to
mountaineer, in three months.
If I post it now, in
two weeks, it will
fall off the radar.
No one will remember that.
No one will be able
to find that.
So for discussions which
are not really
within a day or two--
and it's not just Google+.
It's actually I think
quite a common issue
within social media.
But that's just one of the
comments I have that I think
it would be a good
thing to improve.
JOSEPH SMARR: Yeah, totally.
One thing that excites me
about working on Google+
inside of Google is that so many
of the surfaces I go to
when I'm looking stuff up,
whether it's a Search or I'm
looking up stuff on a map or
I'm going to my calendar or
I'm going to my phone.
These are all, in theory,
surfaces where we can pull
from that stream, including the
deeper contents that have
fallen off when it's only
reverse chronological.
So I think of the content as
going-- that's one of the
reasons why I'm passionate
about History.
Everything that comes in is
collected in this sort of
database of Shares or the
sort of wisdom of
your crowd or whatever.
And I think right now as an
industry, we don't do a very
good job of providing
lots of different
pivots into that database.
But I think there's no reason
why we couldn't and shouldn't.
And you see a bit of that now
with the Search, plus Your
World integration where Google
Search is really reaching into
all the privacy-aware photos
and shares and so forth and
pulling that information out.
But it's just scratching the
surface when you really think
about all the scenarios where
that could be pulled out.
And I think people would share
a lot more if they knew, I am
going to be able to get that
back when I need it.
Or when my friend goes and looks
for that thing three
months from now, they're going
to be able to find that
information.
So I think it creates
a virtuous cycle
if it's done right.
AUDIENCE: Right.
Because yeah, with History, it's
my personal History where
with Share, it's more often
discussion, right?
JOSEPH SMARR: Right.
Although even with your History,
not only you can
share explicitly.
You can also go in and make the
data available to say your
friends Circle or people without
having to make a post
about everything.
And right now, the main way
that surfaces is you go to
somebody's profile, you could
see more of their stuff.
But it's along that whole idea
of just get the data in, make
it available.
And then hopefully we can do
more and more interesting
things over time.
AUDIENCE: But wouldn't making
the History available to
others be the same as a post?
DAVID GLAZER: No.
Great question.
Stick around for the next
session and either grab us in
between or ask afterwards.
There's an important but subtle
difference there.
We have just over
a minute left.
And most of the remaining
platform questions in the
online forum in the moderator
are about History.
So if you ask one of those,
please stick around.
Come back for the
next session.
We can take them there.
And I think--
let me see.
I'm going to put everyone on the
spot and ask you for a 10
second sound bite.
See what happens.
I have no idea.
So I'm vamping just for 20
seconds just so people have
time to come up with
something.
Sort of a closing thought around
the Google+ platform
and either what you learned from
developers today or your
thoughts on what we
should do next.
So Bradley looks like he's
got a mic ready to go.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Sergei,
we need you.
KEN NORTON: Help us make
Google awesome.
SETH STERNBERG: Yeah.
sjs@google.com.
I really want to know what you
guys want to see out of
Google+ as a platform.
CHEE CHEW: For Hangout API, we
tune and design our APIs and
prioritize based upon what
you're trying to do.
And the team holds Hangouts
every Thursday where we engage
and we talk and we get
feedback from you.
Please engage with us.
Come and give us the feedback.
And we will tune our APIs, what
we do and how we do it,
based on your needs.
JOSEPH SMARR: And we
didn't get to talk
about it much today.
But we don't want to just make
Google+ platform social.
We want to make the
whole web social.
And so anything you can do to
help us think through, as we
open up our platform, how we
can do in ways that aren't
just about plugging into our
particular social stack, but
about making social gestures and
profile and identity and
sharing more web native.
We still really care about that
and want to hear your
thoughts about it.
DAVID GLAZER: All right.
Thank you, everyone.
Thank you very much.
Appreciate it.